hey what's up guys my name is the chera
and welcome back to my opengl series so
this is really the first episode of my
opengl series last time we just talked
about what obj actually was a little bit
about how it worked and also what this
series would actually contain if you
guys haven't seen that video then check
it out in that corner today though we're
actually gonna jump in and write some
code when I get some work done we're
going to get an OpenGL window displaying
it maybe even draw a triangle with this
series specifically I want to take a
more practical approach with the C++
series I did a lot of it kind of
explaining a lot of theory before we
actually started writing code I still
want to do that for this for this series
because I believe it's very important to
understand actually how everything works
but with these kind of first few
episodes I just want to get some code
done I just want to actually write some
code and have something happening on the
screen so that hopefully you guys can
kind of feel that sense of progression a
little bit better and then what we'll
actually do is end up kind of as bad as
that goes on maybe once a week or so
have a bit of a theory video and just
talk about how I've been judged if we
works or what actually happens behind
the scenes now that being said our goal
for today is going to be just to create
a winter right I want to be able to have
my operating system create a winter for
me so if my application is actually in
the form of a window and then hopefully
the goal with that is that in the future
we can draw all of our graphics inside
that window now this series specifically
I want don't want to have multi-platform
support right I want people who are
writing this code on Windows Mac and
Linux to also be able to run this code
and it should work on all three
platforms what that means though is that
we need to we need some way to set up
windowing and windowing on and always
creating windows is very very platform
specific so in other words the way that
you the way that you create a window on
Windows is you use the win32 api right
so you actually use the windows api to
say hey i want a window because of
course the way that you create a window
is going to be specific to the operating
system you're using because that's like
an operating system level thing and
that's what I probably would do if I was
writing a game engine I would probably
just take the time to actually set up a
window myself using the actual operating
systems API for each platform that I
actually want to support this series
though isn't about how to write a game
engine that's gonna be another series
later on this series are specifically
about OpenGL and how OpenGL works and
how to write OpenGL code so we don't
really care about how to set up a window
all that we just want to write some
OpenGL code and so because of that I'm
actually gonna use a library that will
basically do that for me and all this
library is going to do is provide me
with the appropriate platform layer so
in other words it's going to provide me
with an implementation of that when
doing creation code and management code
as well for Windows Mac and Linux so
that everyone can follow along with that
and there are several libraries that
allow us to do this but the one that
we're gonna use is something called GL
FW and the reason that I wrote like gfw
is because this is a really kind of
lightweight library all it's going to do
for us is create a window create an open
GL context and give us access to some
basic things like input that's all that
it's going to do it's not like STL which
is like a full kind of they've actually
got like a renderer there so that you
can draw squares or triangles or
whatever you want to the screen and
that'll we implemented in either DirectX
or OpenGL and that that's like a whole
kind of framework I don't want any of
that we're going to be writing our own
stuff all I want to do is automate that
first step of I want to create a window
and I don't want to have to write
different implementations for each
platform
I want this code to be pretty
multi-platform pretty portable so I'm
going to use library like chillip W just
be that off for me
again I could write it myself but that
would mean writing it three times for
each platform when I was back in Linux
in this case and that's just gonna be
waste time and not really the point of
the series
so just want everyone to understand why
I'm actually doing this so yeah let's go
ahead and download shell of W if you go
to the URL that is in the description
below which is Jellicle you'll be taken
to this page we care about basically two
pages here first of all there's just
download shell W 3.2.1
it's exactly what we want but also on
the documentation there's actually some
example code of how to create a window
Engl if W you can see that it's very
very concise right all we have to do is
basically initialize jelf W and then we
could just create our winter and that's
it simple as that if you want to make
our OpenGL context we just call this one
function and then we can start a basic
loop to Paul for events and make sure
that when our window is closed it
actually closes and you can see we can
write OpenGL code right over here it's
it's very very simple and it's pretty
much exactly what we need to get started
so up the top here I'm gonna go back to
jelf W so this download is actually for
all of the source code this is another
thing that I want to mention if I was
writing if this was a game engine series
of something I was actually making a
serious application I would probably
download the source code and build it
myself I would add it as
per project and visual studio and
probably compile it into a static
library and then link it with my main
application just so that if I need to
debug something I had the source code
right there and there's really no
downside to do that
I like having as much source code as I
can in my project however this again is
about OpenGL we don't waste time with
that all I'm going to do is just get
pre-built binaries for my platform and
just build with that right so to do that
I'm going to go to download and then you
can see we have Windows precompiled
binaries so Windows actually has pretty
good binaries lou nixon market says that
you actually have to downloading
compiled source package above there's a
guide so follow that if you're one one
of those platforms I suspect people will
probably run into problems with that
because it's not the most trivial task
and with like make systems like that it
just tends to be all over the place so
if you need help with compiling this
format for Linux definitely join my
discord at the journal at home slash
discord though plenty of people there
who will be happy to help you out with
that specifically but since we're on
Windows and we will be for the entirety
of this series I'm just going to
download the appropriate binaries
another note here we have 32-bit or
64-bit binaries question I get all the
time which one do which one do I get
right a lot of people seem to think that
well I'm running 64-bit Windows so of
course I want zz4 with Windows binaries
that's all that's not correct what you
actually want the the architecture that
matters is the architecture that you're
building for right if we set up our
visual studio project to build for win32
or x86 and we want to get the 32-bit
ones if our application is being built
for 64-bit or x64 right that's where we
want the binary so it's actually the
base what matters is the architecture
the platform of your application so how
you compile your application not not the
operating system you're using
of course the 64-bit application won't
work on a 32-bit operating system but if
you're on a 64-bit operating system like
Windows 10 64 bit you can run either
32-bit applications or 64-bit
applications so the one that you
actually download is going to depend on
on what you compile your application
with so we'll be blue we'll just be
using a 32-bit application because we
don't need a 64-bit one for more serious
projects I probably use 64-bit there's
no real difference it's easy to switch
as well it's not like a whole deal it's
not like we have to write different code
or anything most of the time it's pretty
much the same thing but to keep it
simple we're just gonna use 32 bits
over here I'm gonna click on 32-bit
windows binaries and download that ok so
inside the archive that you download
there'll be a gel W folder and a bunch
of lips we'll talk about setting all
that up in a minute but first we
actually need to create a visual studio
solution so every here I've got visual
studio community 2017 I'm going to click
file new and then projects I'm going to
make sure that I'm under visual C++ and
general and select empty project as my
template we're just going to make a
brand new project from scratch in the
location I'm actually going to change
location from being in My Documents to
basically being C dev YouTube and OpenGL
you can set this to anything else I like
to have I like to keep all of my
development kind of stuff under C dev
that way it's not in a user folder and I
don't have to deal with all that so just
see dev and then open jail or whatever
I've just put it into a YouTube folder
because of course this is for the
youtube series I'm going to call this
OpenGL and just click OK okay so we've
got a visual studio solution and project
setup everything looks pretty good if
you want to set it up properly and more
or less just set it up in a nicer way
because the default Visual Studio way
that it sets up new projects and
solutions is a bit it's a bit weird
check out my video on my kind of
favorite set up for Visual Studio for
C++ so there'll be a link up there I'm
not gonna go through all that right now
it's just gonna take time that's not
really about necessary but definitely
check out that video if you want to know
how I would set this up properly so
again all we're doing today is we're
trying to set up gfw basically as
quickly as possible so in the source
files well one thing I'll actually do is
I'll click on the project name I'll
click on show all files and then I'm
going to actually make a new folder here
called
as I'll say for source so in this show
all files mode actually will mimic our
Windows Explorer file structure and
directory structure and all that again
that's all described in the video that I
linked up there so check that out if
you're not sure under there I'm going to
add a new item I'm going to call this
application bill cpp is going to be our
main file the file with the main
function
I'll hit add and I finally just have a
normal C++ file in my project what I'm
going to do now is just basically
include I always try and make sure
everything is set up in Maine I just
type in STD see out hello and STD seeing
bucket I like to do this just to make
sure everything's set up and everything
will compile you can see we get this
opening with Hello which is perfect so
now I'm ready to actually link Jill if W
and get it to work if I go back to the
GL @w
so here under documentation literally
all I'm going to do here is just copy
pretty much this in this source code
just innocent ID copy and just paste it
over here okay when you get a bunch of
things not working because of course
when you actually setup the library so
let's talk about how I'm gonna set up
jail if W in our project I'm going to go
to that zip archive that I downloaded
with all Val lives there are two things
that matter for us here every kind of
c++ library has include and also lib
right so we're going to talk more in
depth about how syphillis libraries work
and how to link them and all the
differences between all that in a future
video in the c++ series it'll be linked
up there if it's already made but
definitely check that out if you're not
sure about how kind of libraries work in
c++ but out of here what we care about
is the Lib file there's actually two
here the two loop files that we have
here you can see one isn't labeled with
DLL so this one's used for dynamic
linking if you want to use the DLL to
link up runtime GLW 3 dot Lib is the one
that we're going to use though because
that's just for static linking we don't
want to link jilt I'll be dynamically we
don't want to have to use a DLL file
there's no reason for us not a static
link yet so we're going to link it
statically so what I'm going to do is
under OpenGL just gonna right click on
there hit open folder in File Explorer
so that we actually get to our location
of all of this and what I like to do is
in the solution directory so this is the
solution directory the directory with
that solution file I'm going to make a
new folder called dependencies and
inside dependencies I'm gonna make a
folder called feel of W and then it's
like here I'm actually going to put all
the files that I want so out of what I
want in this actual archive that I
downloaded I want include and I wanted
to live vc 2015 which is the latest
visual studio version that we have here
we'll paste this into here of course
we're actually using Visual Studio 2017
although it won't matter for our
purposes it will still work inside here
I can actually delete that DLL file and
the DLL Lib as well we don't need that
and include should just have everything
we need so now what we actually need to
do is tell this project that I want you
to also include this folder for includes
so that we can write code such as
include GLW slash govt 308 right so we
need to add an include directory and
then we also need to add this Lib file
to the linker so that the linker
actually links this loop file in and it
can match up all of the GL FW functions
so let's take a look at how we might set
that up what I'm going to do is right
click on open GL
properties now the most important thing
here I'll just make this smaller the
most important thing here is that your
all configurations okay and all
platforms is really matter
we're just messing with wouldn't that
you do for now but all configurations
make sure you're on all configurations
and not like release if you're editing
release and you're actually in debug
it's not gonna affect your current
conversation configuration you all you
get errors so we want all configurations
under C C++ in general we're going to
add an include directory now what we
could do right is open up our folder
here and just basically copy this path
and put it in there now we don't want to
do that though because other people who
will use this project might not be
storing it in C dev YouTube opengl blah
blah we actually want to make a relative
to the project itself and specifically I
like making it relative to the solution
directory now Visual Studio has a macro
for us that is actually ours current
solution directory if we if we open this
tab here and go to macros then you can
actually type in solution directory and
you'll see what it actually is is cedar
YouTube WebGL survive in jail so
basically what it is is the actual
solution directory that we have here the
directory that has this solution file
and we're actually going to based our
our our include directory path from that
solution directory so I'm going to type
in solution directory that actually
already has a backslash at the end a
trailing backslash so next we'll go into
dependencies jail FW and include in fact
all I'm going to do is copy that last
part and put it over here okay that is
our include directory if you want to
make sure it's correct you can go to
edit here and look at the evaluated
value if you copy that into your file
explorer and hit enter it should take
you to well jail of w and of course now
that you've set that up on the over here
this includes jill w /q o w3 h should
work because we start in this include
directory we're going to the jail toby
folder and there's jail w 3h ok so
that's how we can set up the include
directory next i'm gonna set up my
library directory as well so on the
linker in general i'm going to specify
an additional library directory this
could be very similar to what we had
before gonna start off with solution
directory it's going to go to
dependencies in fact I'm just gonna go
back to my folder and copy the path so
under gfw we have live vc 2015 and there
there it is right so grab that check
that in here and we're good to go on the
input I'm actually going to specify
which file we want to link now we don't
actually need to link all of these I
don't know why they here they feel but
kind of by default but they're actually
included in default libraries so we can
get rid of all that to keep it nice and
clean and just type in GLW 3 don't live
so basically we're linking with this
jillyfell be free to live file again if
I'm going too fast or anything I will
make a video specifically about this in
more detail I just don't want to spend
all day on this so check that out tear
that video out if it's already made it's
not then just wait now another thing we
actually have to link with is OpenGL but
well we'll do it in a minute I'm going
to hit OK because that's all we'll need
for now you can see that all of our
compiler is go away if we hit ctrl f7 to
actually compile our application you can
see each compiled successfully now it's
not gonna link successfully because we
haven't actually you can see we're using
an OpenGL function here but we haven't
links with OpenGL but they can't the
compilation succeeds and that's kind of
all we care about for now now if I right
click build this it's actually going to
compile it and Link the entire
application so let's take a look at that
okay so we get a few things first of all
we have an unresolved external symbol
again I don't I'm not a big fan of
looking at the actual error list you
should be looking at the output because
they are a list is just mostly lies well
not in this case but it can be and this
always gives you more detail ok this
kind of default lib conflicts don't
worry about that that's just a warning
and specifically it's an annoying
warning that we don't need to think
about fixing even it's not that
important this is important however we
have jail clear isn't honest all Excel
we also have a bunch of window stuff
that is unresolved now because I did
actually delete most of the libraries
that we leaked again so we'll bring some
of them back in a minute but the first
one that we're getting which we'll fix
first is GL clear ok and we can actually
get rid of that error by linking with
the opengl library so what's happening
is we're getting a linking error if you
guys don't know how to c++ linker works
check out that video because I have
already made that but basically what
link is trying to do now is find a
definition for that GL clear function
that gel clear function definition is
inside an OpenGL library file so we
actually have to link against that so
our view here in additional dependencies
I'm just gonna add a semicolon type in
OpenGL 32 live if I hit OK and I build
this you can see that that first error
should go away
and in fact now the first time resolve a
sternal symbol is just register device
notification stuff which is basically
Windows kind of API stuff so let's go
ahead and add that in now before we do
that I actually want to show you one way
that you can find these things I've
deliberately gotten rid of all the kind
of windows and clothes because I wanted
to show you guys how this actually works
and how to set it up kind of really from
scratch but if you see errors like this
because they actually do tend to be
quite fog quite common sometimes if you
don't set up correctly you can see that
the function name is actually registered
device notification W so let's grab that
and copy that actually googled R so on
MSDN I'm just gonna google that you can
see we're actually created with MSDN
here which is the Microsoft
documentation so this is the actual
function that we're trying to link and
we don't know where it is so if we
scroll down you can actually see that
the library that it's in is user 32 Lib
so what we can do is copy that and
actually link with that and that that
will actually go away so over here I'll
just type in user 32 Lib hit enter hit
OK and try and build us again you can
see that we get way less errors now
we've only got just a handful now and a
few of them are basically create device
context here and swap buffers and all
that stuff so again when I do the same
thing with this I'm gonna copy this I'm
going to go to guru Kitty Google just
basically Google that function click on
the MSDN link scroll down and you can
see this one is in GDI $32 Lib so back
to my project and I'm going to link
against GDI 32 adult Lib okay I'll hit
OK and try and compile my code again
alright just a few more now drag query
file W again copy that paste it in here
MSDN and here it is shell 32 dot Lib so
back over here you guys kind of get the
drift shell 32 dot Lib okay and build
alright awesome
Norris at all if we hit f5 or just local
windows debugger to run our actual
application you can see that we get a
black screen now all this manual linking
that I've just done you don't need to do
that yourself when you create a new
empty project in Visual Studio like we
did you can see it actually did have a
bunch of links already including like
kernel32 don't live and stuff like that
I just wanted to get rid of them just to
show you how it actually works and how
to link everything kind of from scratch
I hope you don't need to do that they're
just this was just kind of as an example
now we've got a black screen here let's
quickly draw a triangle now what I'm
actually gonna do to draw this triangle
is use legacy
urban
so in the first video we talked about
what a legacy OpenGL was and why we
shouldn't be using this legacy OpenGL is
the fastest way that I can now in like
five lines of code draw a triangle on
the screen and my purpose right now is
just making sure that OpenGL is up and
running
not writing again I'm not writing a
graphics engine right now right so
whilst you shouldn't be using like a
seat OpenGL like in I guess professional
applications is perfectly fine for
debugging people need to realize that
even though some things are discouraged
if you're just writing it temporarily to
test something there's absolutely
nothing wrong with it so here's keep
that in mind so what we're gonna do over
here I'm to jail clear because I'm
actually just gonna type in jail begin
jail triangles and this you and you guys
will kind of get it to experience and
legacy OpenGL cars so between jail
beginning GL end we just want to specify
three vertices I want to type in jail
vertex to F which is going to specify it
to component kind of vertex or 2d I
guess vertex now by default our
projection matrix in OpenGL is between
negative one and one in all in every
dimension in every axis we'll talk more
about projection matrices and all this
fun stuff in future videos again just
trying to draw a triangle now so I'm
going to type in negative 0.5 F and then
negative 0.5 F for y as well and then
for my other ones I'm going to maybe
make this one in the middle so it's
going to be just 0 F for X and also a
positive 0.5 F for Y and this one's
going to be positive 0.5 for X and
negative 0.5 for y so I should be
drawing a triangle that is basically in
this shape let's hit f5 and you can see
that I get a triangle is perfectly kind
of be in the middle of my screen and
looks pretty good okay so we can now
conclude that OpenGL is working and
that's gonna wrap up this video we've
basically accomplished everything we
wanted to we've got an OpenGL window
everything right now is in our
application file we are probably going
to move it just into a class or
something just to keep it a bit more
simple we'll do that next time
but overall again we're not going to
spend too much time creating an API for
ourselves because we want to learn
OpenGL
so we've got something up and running
you guys can recreate this code on your
computer and hopefully get something as
well so you can finally making a nice
little cute OpenGL application which
draws a single triangle exciting stuff I
know if as we go as we go on what kind
of deal with more stuff now for all the
code in this series I do actually
encourage that you copy it down yours
sells because when you actually copy
code even even though you are just
copying from a screen you actually learn
it because you're typing it out yourself
it's like when you meet someone new a
lot of times you'll meet someone you
don't introduce themselves and say their
name and then you'll just forget their
names right away but if you actually say
their name back to them like hello Bob
then you'll actually you're way more
likely to remember their name right so
kind of with this as well I like I like
the idea of people actually copying code
down themselves and actually physically
typing it themselves because once you do
that muscle memory will kind of kick in
and you'll actually learn a lot faster
that being said if you really want the
source code I am actually making that
available to patrons so if you pledge on
the show no TOCOM slash patreon I'll
sorry if you put on patreon a conference
after China probably make the show not a
complex patron work as well but if you
go to patreon.com/scishow no and you
pledge their you help support this
series you will actually get access to
the code on github and that will be
separate for each episode as well just
like it is for my other other series so
if you really want to source code that
you really want to help spoil the series
it's just you basically you just get a
reward for helping to support the series
and making sure that I can make more
videos there's also a bunch of other
rewards on patreon of course after
Jenner so I really appreciate all the
help I get from there and that's what
basically lets me sit down and make
these videos properly so much
appreciated anyway next time we're gonna
abstract this out into a class and
actually talk about a modern OpenGL
because what we've done right now is
we've created an OpenGL context and a
window and everything we're actually
only limited to using OpenGL 1.1 which
is what ships with Windows Windows
doesn't Windows has its own rendering
API Direct X direct3d so they don't
actually provide you will the functions
you need for modern OpenGL as I
mentioned in the welcome to OpenGL video
that's provided for us by our GPU
drivers so what we need to do next time
is actually somehow get all those
functions that are in newer versions of
OpenGL app from algae and from our GPU
drivers so that we can actually what we
want to be able to call the functions
right so that's what we need to do in
this what we'll talk about next time a
little probably moving this out into a
class and all that fun stuff and then
that's when the real funs gonna begin
next time so I'll see you guys in the
next video goodbye
it's true
[Music]